Hello, everybody. This is going to be a video on the phase angle in cancer. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters
and for help people understand what the phase angle is. The phase angle is measured when you're coming in our office, other clinics, measure phase angle cancer treatments that are America, I believe, measures phase angle
typically oncologists don't
And I don't know for what reason, but we're going to look at what phase angle is most the studies on phase angle are with cancer patients
And we want to see how we're going to look at that. So what is a phase angle? A phase angle is a ratio between what's called the reactants and the resistance
When you test a person with a bio impedance analysis test
So a bio impedance analysis is a specific instrument that will you hook up little electrodes to the head and little electrodes to the feet to the same side
And then the machine puts a little teeny electrical impulse in and it measures the resistance across the cell membranes
As that electrical impulse travels through the course of the body
So it's that resistance across the cell membrane that's put into a calculation
The mathematical calculation that tells us what's called the phase angle and it's really measuring the cell membrane integrity
So your cell membrane, if you remember from biology class, is a phospholipid bilayer
So it's two layers of this phospholipid long lipid shade with a phosphorous group
And what that phospholipid bilayer has a hydrophilic and hydrophobic side
And I'm not going to get into cell biology here too deeply, but that cell membrane is really the health of the cell
Some people call it actually the brain of the cell
There's thousands of receptors embedded in it
calcium, mineral channels embedded in it
Different channels where nutrients get in the cell and exit the cell
The receptors are where different proteins and enzymes attach to that receptor of the cell membrane that are specific for that specific
Nutrienter or hormone or protein or enzyme in that turns on different things kind of like a lock and key mechanism
That turns on different processes in the cell
Very important for cancer patients because many of those processes are apoptotic processes
How a cell will go through normal cell death
It turns on a cascase process that will turn on a cell death process within the cell
Very important the health of the cell membrane we could say the health of a person's cell membrane is
Literally equated to the health of the person
So your cell membrane and your cytoplasm the gelatinous water inside the cell
Is really what is what we're trying to affect when we're trying to increase the person's cell health and increase their overall health
So that's what we're looking at what the person
That what is a normal phase angle so a phase angle is read from zero to about 11 11.5 if you're at a zero
You'd be you'd be dead for a couple days you even you have a cell charge a phase angle
Think of it as your cell charge the cell membrane charge the cytoplasm charge
And you even have a cell you even have a phase angle after you pass away
It takes a few days for that phase angle to go down to zero
But in a healthy person your phase angle would range anywhere between 5.0 to 10 now we have had um
I don't remember anybody measuring you know
Higher than 10 points something
But the younger the person is the higher the phase angle will be because
They haven't been exposed to many toxins many poisons many things that damage our cell membranes
And you're going to have a higher cell a higher phase angle read
So an adult normal adult with no disease process fairly healthy
In their 20s is going to have a phase angle usually between 7 and 9
There was a time where I treated a number of the medicine of Vikings players
And their phase angles were the high sevens eights
Up to low nides
But just because they're wonderful athletes doesn't necessarily mean they eat well and they're their cell health is really that great
So
As we get sick as disease processes take place somebody with cancer could have a phase angle between 5 and 6.5
I typically tell patients I want to see their phase angle at 5.5 or higher that would be
uh
More
Advantages for the patient their ability to heal would be better
We've had patients where their phase angle is in the twos
That's a very very ill person
Chance of recovery is it's much more grim. It's more difficult because again the phase angle is the charge of the cell the health of the cell membrane the health of that cell cytoplasm
How well it carries a charge
Um, and that is all important
So
We want to raise that person's phase angle, but how does the phase angle get bad? What does it tell us so most research on phase angle is done on cancer patients
And the lower the phase angle suggests that deterioration or a loss of healthy charge of that cell membrane again
In advanced cancer patients
It may result in reduced overall survival rates again most of the studies on phase angle are done with
With cancer patients and are measured as the cancer patient goes through treatment and usually that treatment with the studies is is
Standards of care so the person is going through chemotherapy or radiation and most of the studies show is if the
persons
Phase angle
Plumbits during their treatment phase the overall survival also plummets meeting the chance of that person surviving their care
Goes down dramatically if we could keep the person's phase angle level
If it was in a pretty safe category if it was above 5.0 if we could keep it at that the chance of the overall survival is greater
If we could get the phase angle to rise that's even better news for the patient if the phase angle is going down
Especially dramatically that's not as good now understand phase angles are going to shift all that
uh
Rapidly so if a person has a comes in we test their phase angle. Let's say it's at 5.5
Quit them on a clean diet clean about detoxifying them. They're using the right machine. They're using some other instrumentation
And we measure it and get in a month
It's it might not shift at all. It still could be 5.5
Let's say they do everything right in three months. It could be 5.7
So there's not going to be these drastic changes in phase angle
We've seen some drastic changes, but overall you're typically not going to see that
Where you can see drastic changes is if a person is doing chemotherapy they could drop for the 5.5 to a 4.3
That's typically not a good sign
So uh even if they're doing everything right if they're if their cell charge is being lost because of
Being poisoned by different things and that's that's not a good sign that that's really where the studies
Have shown with cancer patients at phase angle
So how do you improve your phase angle? How do I change this? How do I improve?
But if I have to do chemotherapy if I'm not doing chemotherapy and I'm starting with the phase angle of 5.5 or 4.5
Or even worse than that. What do I do? So
Detoxification is important because again that cell membrane is that phospholipid bilayer
That is the problem with bad fats like trans fats. They actually
Superimpose over and into the phospholipid bilayer and actually
Cause kind of a plasticized cell membrane. So
the receptors are displaced and
Not usable and the
Channels where nutrients get inside the cell are not usable and it basically
Kind of smothers the cell. That's why bad fats aren't bad for us and they can kill us because they
Over time displaced phospholipid
By layer cells and then take that place inside the cell membrane and damage the cell in the cell can die
And you do that to a number of cells and we're in trouble. So
We want to detoxify heavy metals
Large chemicals damage that cell membrane can embed itself in those cell membranes
So we want to detoxify so we talk about detoxified
This is not a lecture at detoxification, but we want to go backwards from
Then what we could call phase 3.5 getting stuff out of the colon of the kidneys to
Three getting it out of the liver and out through the bile duct to 2.5 getting it conjugated in the liver so we could get it out of the bile duct to
phase 2 where you're
Conjugating it and changing it in water soluble
Particles these are toxins. We're talking about in the liver and to all the way backwards to phase 1 or phase 0
Get it out of the cell membrane into the blood to get it into the liver to get it into the
Bile duct to get it into the colon to get it into the toilet
So these levels of detoxification we want to go backwards and up to that
Pulling it out of the cell pulling it out of the cell membrane
Get it into the blood to get it out of the body. So detoxification is huge and key if you want to improve your health
You have to detoxify
Bottom line you are what you don't detoxify. So
That's the key. So if you get it out of your body
It's going to become a part of your cell either inside the cytoplasm of the cell or inside the cell membrane
It's going to drop your phase angle your charges and going to be there. You're going to die in early death
That's what causes cancer and that's what we're trying to prevent when you're dealing with a cancer patient
That's what you're trying to prevent before you have cancer. So detoxification is key. That's important number one
Proving overall health ties into that. So your changing your diet your changing your overall health changing your your thought process
Everything you possibly could do to exercise to take care of yourself the proving overall health is going to help yourself your
phasing or your cell membrane health
adding good fats phosphylcoline and paredessential oils is key
No, this we use a paredessential oil
From php and body bio
PC which is by far the best phosphylcoline on the market
Those are good fats that you can take but just doing those alone without doing these other things is is going to not be a good thing
Rife is key so rife technology using light frequencies to help add charge to the cell membrane and and bring charge back to the cell in the cytoplasm
Is absolutely key in my book and I have lots of videos on rife technology and why that's important
And that's a big piece you talk about oh rife is going to kill the cancer cells
Well, yes, that is taking place, but if it's doing nothing but bringing
Electrical integrity back to the cell membrane or the cytoplasm of the cell you have improved that person's life tremendously
And you're going to help be able to take a cancer cell and turn it into a normal cell again meeting that it's not going to replicate anymore
That's the key to rife technology added PEMF pulse electromagnetic frequency
Machine can be very helpful to either low or high frequency machines. I believe both help in aid in
Cell membrane and cytoplasm potential
So those are key components to help with that as well
All right, hopefully this helped you understand a little bit about phase angle
The questions that I've had with this well, where do I get my phase angle checked
There's certain instrumentation that's better than other we use the rjl instrumentation which according to the navy who did
Number of studies on this the us navy. They said that that is the best instrumentation. That's the instrumentation
They've used that's why I picked that instrumentation
um
You go to a clinic typically. It's going to be a cancer clinic. That's going to have phase angle testing equipment
Again, I said I'm pretty sure my patients have said
Cancer treatments in America those centers have them
We've used them for over a decade
It's been great instrumentation to be able to say how well a person is doing and again the negative of it is
You're not going to change that phase angle quickly
So you're not going to like you're not going to change by diet change everything and add a rife at PEMF and by phase angles
Go from 5.5 to 7.0 in a month. It just doesn't do it that way
It takes time to change your cells and you have to be patient and start doing the right thing
That's why we often say that it took 20 years for you to get cancer
Maybe the cancer wasn't growing in you 20 years. Sometimes it is but um the ill health
Took place over 20 years the choices of life the exposures to toxins
The mercury toxicity the whatever it was that brought your total health cell health down
um is
What um
caused the ill health in the first place and it's going to take time to get better
So be patient with yourself start doing the right things start adding these things
A lot of our patients are from a distance so they don't get back to get their phase angle
Rechecked is it important? No, it's not important. You just continue to do the right things
You just keep doing the right thing
You don't necessarily need to measure it again
Because you just keep doing the right thing. So I know we live in an analytical world
And everybody wants to know but we can't always do that
But so our local patients have the ability to get their phase angle checked when we do that on a regular basis
Hopefully it was helpful. This is Dr. Kevin Connors
You could contact me that left head quarter cutters clinic and we will talk soon. Thanks